some important news just in for you and
buckingham palace
has just announced that the duke of
edinburgh has died
he was 99 years old
we don't know any more detail on that
for you yet we will
bring that to you as soon as we know it
but we can bring in our royal
correspondent for you
rihannon mills rihannon
this will come as deeply upsetting news
for the royal family
the royal household and most
significantly
her majesty the queen in a statement
that has just been
released by the palace they say it is
with deep sorrow that her majesty the
queen
has announced the death of her beloved
husband his raw
highness the prince philip duke of
edinburgh it goes on to say that his
royal highness passed away peacefully
this morning
at windsor castle for almost eight
decades
the duke of edinburgh was a constant
figure
by the queen side and an integral and
much-loved member of the royal family
and a truly unforgettable character
it was of course his marriage that
really placed him
at the center of national life at a time
really when
it was men who were head of the
household it was men
who held those positions of power and
yet he found himself
always in that supporting role as
supporting his wife
a role that he loyally fulfilled for his
entire life but i think now as we
have that opportunity to really look
back
on his life he really has left behind
the most
remarkable personal legacy whether it's
through his career in the navy
his charity work his support for the
queen
and also his efforts throughout the
decades to really modernize the monarchy
of course over the next week the royal
family
and the country will prepare to pay
their respects
to him for his funeral but it will also
be
i think an important opportunity to
really recognize
his extraordinary commitment that he
showed throughout the years to
his family that unfaltering dedication
to the queen as britain's
longest-serving consort
it also is going to be a real
opportunity for people to
look past that image of an elderly man
that we've seen
in recent decades who yes quite
frequently made the headlines because of
his no-nonsense character
but now really is an opportunity for the
royal family
for the country and also people right
across the commonwealth
to celebrate remember that important
life of public service
and duty from fighting during the second
world war
to becoming britain's longest serving
consort